of these Stimpson lectures that are
being delivered by anne-marie slaughter
the spends the Stimson lectures are
sponsored by the Macmillan Center and
Yale University Press the funding came
from a an anonymous donor in honor of
Henry L Stimson we don't get too many
anonymous donors anymore Henry Stimson
was Yale College class of 1889 an
attorney and statements statesman whose
government service culminated with his
tenure as Secretary of War during World
War two the Stimson lecture series are
published by the Yale University Press
and some really remarkable books have
come out in that series
perhaps Samuel Huntington's best book
political order in changing societies
was what was Stimson lectures also
Schelling's arms and influence the Arab
Center promise of moderation by Marwan
Masha and soon to be published Michael
walls is what happened to National
Liberation Anne Marie slaughter is the
president and CEO of New America a in a
non-partisan think tank that was created
about 15 years ago a little more 1999
before that she was the officer she
served as the director of policy
planning for the US Department of State
and if I was just looking down the list
of previous incumbents in that role this
is a position that was actually created
in 1947 for George Kennan when he when
he came back from Moscow at the
beginning of the Cold War before he fell
out with the Truman administration and
went off in a half to Princeton it's
what people send to do but if you look
down the list of people of service are
really a remarkable I'll just mention
some of them Paul Nitze
Walt Rostow Winston Lord Tony Lake Mort
Halpern and one of the things you
noticed when you get to any slaughter is
2009 she was the first woman to serve
and it's a very important role in in
planning I think plant policy planning
maybe understates the importance of that
role it's also a massive with the
coordinating role about forward thinking
about foreign policy she also went back
to Princeton but not in a half to become
Dean of the Woodrow Wilson School before
that I would just say if you look at
this I'm not going to spend time because
nobody came here to listen to me today
but if you look at the sub sir and
subsequent trajectories of people who
served in the office of policy planning
in that directors role I think it's a
fair bet to say that Anna Marie
slaughter will has not done with
government - shall we say least many of
us hope she's not done with government
before that as I said she was Dean in
the Woodrow Wilson School and before
that an eminent member of the Harvard
Law School faculty she's written or
edited several books including the New
World Order and the idea that is America
keeping faith with our values in a
dangerous world and she's a frequent
contributor to many publications
including the Atlantic and she publishes
a lot through Project Syndicate as well
where her work is widely syndicated she
wrote as I'm sure everyone in this room
knows an article called why women still
can't have it all for the Atlantic which
became their most read article in the
history of the magazine and helped spark
a renewed debate on the continued
obstacles to genuine full male-female
equality that grew into her most recent
book unfinished business which is still
on a book tour for I gather yeah and
you've taken time out for that to talk
about what's going to be her new book
that Stimson lectures book the overall
idle strategy of connection they focus
on three themes first the chessboard and
the web second strategies for reliance
action and scale which were yesterday in
the day before and her lecture today is
power policy and leadership in a
networked well a networked world I'm
pleased and privileged to introduce to
you Anne Marie slaughter welcome
spectacular day out there and it is also
a Friday and to see all of you on the
third lecture is truly an honor so we
started on on Wednesday outlining two
very different optics on the world the
chessboard view of traditional
geopolitics which is what you might
think of as the kissing Jerian view the
view of states the view of eternal
competition and conflict the view of
strategy as some kind of game I use the
chessboard but it could also be poker it
could also be a coordination game but it
is the world that Thomas Schelling wrote
about in the strategy of connection of
conflict which essentially took as a you
know zero-sum conflictual relationship
between the United States and the Soviet
Union and turned it into a partial
positive son bargaining game and that
has underpinned foreign policy strategy
and courses and international relations
ever since so I we showed showed you how
to think of the world simultaneously in
terms of the chessboard and the web
these are not opposite the they may be
opposites but they're not mutually
exclusive you have to learn to see in
stereo to see at the same time that
world of 195 countries that are in the
UN and the 5222 ten to five great powers
who are making trouble or you need in a
coalition and to see the world as a
networked web of what are a web of
networks networks of businesses civic
organizations individuals
Jools universities government officials
and criminals I so that's a lot flexion
yesterday because what that tells us is
we when we think about the chessboard
world we've got tools we know how to
apply game theory we know how to play
tit for tat we know how to create
coalition's that will put pressure we
know how to bluff those are still in the
Situation Room the basic categories of
foreign policy strategy even if no one
who is sitting there knows that I often
used to say that I could that people
would ask me what it was like being an
academic in Washington and I would have
multiple answers one of which was I
never heard the word academic used to
mean anything good
it could mean irrelevant it could mean
silly it could make me but it never
meant anything good but the other thing
I used to say is I could sit in those
meetings and think you don't know it but
that's Robert cohan's after hegemony you
don't know it but that's shelling the
strategy of conflicts so I or it's I'm
at Yale you don't know it that's Bruce
russets writing on democracies and many
others so as a scholar those ideas do
matter and and but my point is there's
no comparable set of ideas of categories
of strategies for networks that we can
map networks and in this conversation
we've been talking about the military's
way ahead of us here and then the
intelligence community they they do map
networks but when you get to the States
Statesman States people really does
sound kind of awful the the the leaders
the thinkers then they don't have any
positive notion of how to create a
network and for what purpose so
yesterday's lecture was this here are
three categories of networks resilience
networks action networks and scale
networks each of those had three sub
categories defense networks response
networks the the I'm not going to go
through all nine of them but each each
sub and in each one I put forward
here's what the structure of the network
should look like at least as a starting
point here's so here's the structure of
how you connect people here's who should
be connected and here's how you should
act within those networks to make them
positive tools of strategy so today
we're gonna talk about what that means
for the actual policymaking process any
of you who are observant will notice I'm
actually going to talk about policy
power and leadership in that order
rather than I'm gonna put a policy first
then we're going to talk about the
nature of power and how you have to
think about power to be able to wield it
effectively in networks and finally
we're going to conclude with how you
lead in a networked world all right so
yeah I didn't even know we had a podium
well okay if we can do this as long as I
can use my well we've managed this so
far we'll we'll manage okay so so we
can't actually formulate and implement
strategies of connection unless as I
said we change our lenses on the nature
of power change our education for and
practice of policymaking and change our
understanding of leadership but again
and I'm going to come back to this at
the end this is not either/or you're
gonna you have to think about this kind
of power and this kind of policymaking
in this kind of leadership at the same
time that you think more about the more
traditional ways and we'll come back to
that so start with policy and by policy
I mean the tools and process necessary
for the solution of public problems I
say as Dean of a public policy school as
somebody in the State Department now is
someone who runs a think-tank and civic
enterprise those are all just different
companies in the same industry and the
industry is the solution of public
problems so that's how I define policy
the tools and process necessary to solve
public problems so we start as I said
that to solve public problems in a
network
world in the web world that requires the
optical shift I outlined in the first
lecture it means that you have to think
about the web not the chessboard that's
not just an optical shift though it's a
deeper intellectual shift it's an
ontological shift in how we not just how
we see the world but what we perceive
the world to be and I'll just say when I
was a graduate student at Harvard in the
1980s this was the word you threw
through around to intimidate everybody
else you would talk about an ontology
that's an ontological shift and it made
you sound oh so knowledgeable and very
and it was very hard to grasp but it is
just essentially an ontology is what you
think exists so when I say it's an on
top ontological world what I imagine the
world to be is different when I'm
thinking in the web world than the chest
bird world because remember there's no
no actual thing out there called the
international system right there's no
thing there there's the United Nations
and their embassies and there are all
sorts of things you could say are part
of it but it's in our heads so this is
an ontological shift so that shift has
to we if that shift has to begin in how
we define and teach policy which and
policy is not a discipline it's a
mindset and a set of skills so I was as
Ian mr. Shapiro has told you the Dean of
this other public policy school at this
other university in New Jersey the
Woodrow Wilson School for seven years
and we we educated young people aspiring
to go into a career in government or in
non-governmental organizations or
sometimes in in business people who
wanted to be able to make and implement
policy so we required them to learn a
great deal about economics and
statistics some politics and some
psychology focused on judgment and
decision making we taught them to write
crisp concise and focused memos and we
offered them electives in international
relations development policy economic
policy and what would and domestic
policy you know going to policy school
to prepare for a school and to
prepare for a career in government is
itself a relatively new phenomenon it's
particularly new at Yale but but it's
even even with respect to the other
policy schools when I was educated in
the 1970s in the 1980s the leading
preparation for government official 'dom
was law school hours is a government of
laws after all and so you know that's
what you needed you you needed to learn
how to draft read parse interpret meta
interpret twist and clarify the language
of laws and regulations and apply those
skills to any area of substance within
government and within government so it
could be agriculture or foreign policy
the point was it was the language of law
so even beyond that at the more meta
level all public problems could be
reduced to the language of rights and
duties
the who had the rights and who had the
duties so any question of public policy
if you had to solve it from the legal
perspective is where are you going to
place who has the right who has the duty
that of course as I'm going to say then
determines who pays for what so law
schools existed alongside schools of
public administration which got down to
the nitty-gritty of budgeting and
bureaucratic administration a kind of
business school for civil servants and
local and state government elected
officials policy schools or schools of
Public and International Affairs as we
know them today were largely creatures
of the second half of the 20th century
and frankly they were and are in a
permanent identity crisis and I look at
Jim Levinson there I think he would
agree with me hi there's no meeting of
Dean's of a public policy school where
summer schools of international affairs
summer schools of public administrations
summer schools of public affairs summer
schools of government there is no
agreement on what they truly are but the
one thing they do agree on is the need
for policymakers to be fluent in the
language not of law but of economics
another language that translates all
problems not into rights and duties but
rather costs and benefits and when
you're learning its policy analysis
that's what you're learning you're
learning how to
read data but ultimately how to think
what is this going to be effective or do
the benefits outweigh the costs and more
broadly now the language of data and
statistics generally as government's
increasingly embrace evidence-based
policies so we're learning how to
marshal that evidence and how to present
it we never required at least at the
Woodrow Wilson School I will not speak
for the Jackson Institute just to study
anything about technology even the
structure the physical properties and
the governance of the Internet the world
we all increasingly inhabit it's a
little like not teaching basic geography
like not knowing where the Atlantic and
the Pacific oceans are right because
you're living in the virtual world and
you don't even understand the basic
parameters and structure and geography
of it and although we taught the
bureaucratic politics of traditional
hierarchies we taught nothing about the
nature and structure of networks so what
we should be teaching I put to you is
the network mindset not only asking and
thinking about who is connected to whom
or what is connected to what
but the trickier business of mentally
converting three-dimensional human
relationships into two-dimensional maps
of connection I want to I want to focus
on this for a minute because this is
this is critical to what I'm talking
about and it's not easy
so think about think about if we were to
think about this room and think about
all the connections between all of you
some are students some are teachers some
are friends youie some are alumni you
have all different relationships and we
think about that in three-dimensional
space we think you know I'm here you and
I had dinner last night we can we that
is a relationship I'm asking you with a
network map mindset to take that
three-dimensional relationship and map
it in two-dimensional space it's
actually going backwards because we
normally take two-dimensional space and
then convert it into the
three-dimensional business of living
this is actually taking that
three-dimensional space and learning how
to see
all relationships when I look at this
room I think of a network map I think I
could draw all the connections between
you and then I think which of you would
be the biggest connectors who are the
people who are most connected to others
and and who is the mother that makes
them the most central in that network
and then what does that mean and what
can I do with that that's a mindset that
needs to be taught every bit as much as
the language of law having taught
first-year law students for a long time
and teaching them how to speak in the
language of law and think in the
language of law but equally teaching
policy students how to think in the
language of law of economics and
statistics which I have also done so we
need to teach the networked mindset so
we're accustomed to reducing human
beings to data points and to
manipulating the resulting information
that we know how to do that statistics
right all those dots are people and we
turn them into data but seeing the world
in terms of networks means translating
the emotional professional or digital
space between people and objects
it means translating the emotional
professional our digital space between
people and objects into these maps
okay here we go so that's what I was
looking for so that shift in mindset is
the is like asking people who see a
black object on a white ground to see a
white object on a black ground and I
assume you all know this picture right
we look at the black well it's very hard
actually for me to do so if you look one
way you see the old lady right and if
you look the other way you see the
beautiful young woman and that does
everybody see that so that's actually
what I'm asking people to
not everybody sees that Anderson's
having trouble but that's alright you
keep staring at it my point is that's
exactly what I'm asking people to do
when you think about networks I'm asking
when we see that three-dimensional space
of people okay I'm gonna have to change
this slide because nobody's gonna listen
to a word I say for the rest of this let
me see if I can do it here I can
sometimes oh yes okay so well there is
one way to see it where the black part
here is the top of an old woman's head
and there's a big ugly nose and then you
see her chin down here and there's
another way to see it so that's the
pretty lady and that's your eyelash
there there we go okay so my point is
this is it's that kind of movement you
have to make to think of the world
simultaneously in three and two
dimensions so when we see then
disconnected people or objects we must
be thinking of how they should be
connected so this is a whole lot easier
to read the slide if you think about the
world in terms of networks it's not just
that you think oh how are people
connected on the complete network or in
these networks you also think about
people who are not connected and how
they could be and actually you know in
math this is a network right for most of
us that's not a network a network has to
be connected but when graph theory
that's just as much a network it's just
an empty network so it's again it's a
way of thinking about people and their
connections and their lack of
connections so I actually have to say I
think in terms of thinking in terms of
networks or not I do think there's a
gender component here but I'm not going
to go into it today that's a whole
nother subject so but teaching students
how to solve public problems which again
is the business that policy schools are
in ought to then include a course in
digital and Human Geography bringing
together the work of all the many
disciplines that I've drawn on in these
lectures and as I said yesterday that's
mathematics physics sociology
organizational Theory psychology
technology it's an enormous range of
disciplines moreover a network map
will become the new memo at least in
terms of laying out the dimensions of a
particular policy problem for your boss
our writing and technical skills courses
must teach students the technology to
create read and manipulate networked
representations because how else are you
going to see the world that you then
want to manipulate policymaking
processes themselves will also have to
change often in the State Department
Secretary Clinton would call for a deep
dive on a particular subject which would
mean that a group of diplomat diplomatic
and intelligence experts would gather
around a table for a couple of hours to
present a briefing on a subject like the
nature of Isis very topical today or the
North Korean nuclear problem the brief
words would present data they'd analyze
and interpret it and policy options
would be reviewed in the web world that
briefing would start with Network Maps
the very entities that we have to focus
on our networks and it's essential then
to start by understanding who is
connected to whom where and how so to
build on a great question that one of
you asked me yesterday I don't think it
might have been you Mike but you'll tell
me if it was somebody said look
sometimes these networks in Afghanistan
and Pakistan just keep extending and
extending what happens when it just gets
too big for the actual problem so I'm
not sure the person who asked me is here
that was not you what's you it was you
it was Mike okay I'm gonna come back to
you in a second so to build on that
question Richard Holbrooke insisted when
he became Special Representative for the
war in Afghanistan that he be named
Special Representative for Afghanistan
and Pakistan quickly shortened to a spec
he insisted at every turn that everyone
starts saying and thinking AfPak to
emphasize the inextricably
interconnected nature of the problem he
succeeded the Pakistanis hated it just
absolutely hated that they hated the
meetings they hated the term the last
thing they wanted to do was to be put
together with the Afghans
all in the way we thought in the
meetings we held but even in succeeding
we were still always talking about to
States to governments and to diplomatic
delegations they they were connected at
the chessboard level but not at the web
level the key policy question was always
then how to get the two states to
cooperate better and I sat through many
meetings with Secretary Clinton and the
Pakistani and Afghan a delegation and
they were not happy meetings and so you
were trying to get them to cooperate or
else we were figuring out how the US
could apply carrots or sticks to one of
them to get them to cooperate or with
the other so if we were making policy to
counteract the Taliban in the web world
we would start with the Taliban al Qaeda
Network regardless of borders we would
continually asking ourselves ask
ourselves what was working or was what
was not working with regard to the
network not the countries the network
spreads across the military does often
think that way but the State Department
most assuredly does not we would think
about how to build counter networks not
just counter terrorist networks we're
good on counter terrorist networks
that's all over the place but that's not
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
counter social networks counter
assistance networks counter political
networks we would see the problem as a
network and underpinning that network is
not just military prowess it is social
assistance it is tribal lengths and we
would then think about how do you
disrupt it and how do you counter it in
multiple ways so as I told you once
again that wouldn't mean that the
traditional diplomatic analysis would
stop that's crazy it's an incredibly
complicated world you wouldn't stop
thinking about how to pressure the two
governments you wouldn't stop thinking
about you know how in the end you could
get other regional players to pressure
the two governments which is actually
what ambassador Holbrooke wanted which
was to be to bring in India and to bring
in Iran and create a kind of regional
settlement absolutely that would still
be important
that would be chessboard strategy but at
the same time you would be thinking
about the networks these networks and
how to counter them and how to counter
them precisely with the kinds of
networks I talked about yesterday
whether resilience networks or scale
networks or action networks alright so
let's turn now to power policymaking is
obviously intertwined with power artwork
of governance of shape of answering
public problems cannot be divorced from
power in so what we're gonna talk about
is what is power in the web world and
how do we exercise it successfully in
2009 I wrote an article entitled
America's edge power in the networked
world and I argued and I'm going to
quote here the emerging networked world
of the 21st century exists above the
state below the state and through the
state this is by the way the article
that led Secretary Clinton to appoint me
as director of policy planning so
there's a sense of thinking quite
differently in this world the state with
the most connections will be the central
player able to set the global agenda and
to unlock innovation and sustainable
growth the measure of power in the
networked world is connectedness the
degree and quality of the connections a
person an institution or a government
can make and I want to stop here for a
second just to say that this idea first
hit me in 1982 when I was a first-year
law student and I read Carroll
gilligan's in a different voice and
Carol Gilligan is a psychologist who had
done a great deal of work with
adolescent girls and boys and the book
was about how adolescent girls think
about morality differently than
adolescent boys and that is they there
that generated a huge amount of response
and and again it would take three
lectures just to go through but she said
there are two ways to think about power
there is a hierarchy I'm sorry there's a
ladder and in a ladder world power flows
from the top and then there is a web and
she had a kind of spider web she didn't
have this the webs we're talking about a
spider web and
in a web world power flows from the
center and it was revolutionary to me
because I really wasn't interested at
being at the top of a hierarchy but I
was deeply interested in being at the
center of a web of being connected of
knowing what was going on of being able
then to gather and mobilize people so I
start with that there as I said there is
a gendered component here I actually
don't think I think there there are
gender dimensions but these are two ways
anybody can think about power clearly al
Qaeda thinks about power in terms of a
web so so my point was that if you think
about the world that way American power
looked very different this is 2009 this
is right after the financial crisis
American stock is very low and my point
was no no if you think about the world
as a world of networks America has the
population the geography the culture to
actually be one of the central nodes
there's never going to be just one one
central node so so but I argued then and
I'm gonna elaborate now the power that
flows from this type of connectivity is
not the power to impose outcomes
networks are not directed and controlled
so much as they are managed and
orchestrated multiple players are
integrated into a whole that is greater
than the sum of its parts an orchestra
that plays differently according to the
vision of its conductor and the talent
of its individual musicians and quote I
think it's interesting to note that we
use the word orchestrate to talk about
networks if you just read the network
literature that comes up over and over
again think about how a conductor
actually exercises power over an
orchestra it is not the power to impose
it might be in rehearsal he can expel
you but in the moment of the concert he
is not imposing he's evoking and he is
evoking something that is so much
greater than the sum of its parts
music in that sense is the ultimate
example of emergence so to wield that
kind of power properly the power to
evoke rather than to impose we need to
understand it better and I'm gonna do
that here by focusing first on the power
of networks how networks themselves can
be powerful and then we're going to talk
about power
in networks which will then lead us to
leadership and how you actually wield it
so the power of networks is both
organizational and relational the there
are seats here Lina you don't have to
stand there come on up
so both organizational and relational
they are an organizational form much
better adapted to the speed technology
democracy and uncertainty of 21st
century life so here we're going to go
back this is Walter Powell's work from
1990 it takes he's this very prominent
social sociologist
it takes a long time for these ideas to
penetrate so he he argued in 1990 in a
paper that was called power markets
networks and hierarchies introducing
networks as an intermediate form between
the transitory bargaining relationships
of markets the invisible hand right we
all just bargained with each other
supply and demand and the thick
structures of hierarchies so in
hierarchies obviously it is it is it
determined and formalized the the nature
the way in which people interact and he
said networks were in between right they
they had the the speed and the flex yeah
well let me quote him here in his words
networks quote networks are particularly
apt for circumstances in which there is
a need for efficient reliable
information the most useful information
is rarely that which flows down the
formal chain of command in an
organization hierarchies or that which
can be inferred from shifting price
signals and it's just it's just not
determinant enough the market
information so what so he says look in a
obviously in a fast changing world where
you need information networks are fast
and they're flexible but they are
formalized enough that you can actually
get that information you actually you
have the ability to think about how you
ping your your your friends on email or
in social media right you need
information you send out the signal you
get it back but you get it back in a
very fast and flexible way so the the
way
in which speed and democracy in the
sense of mass participation or let me
let me rephrase that a little bit
here's how to think about the power of
networks it fort to provide information
in a very fast changing world here's the
story of Mona Eltahawy who is a
well-known Egyptian American blogger
with thousands and that tens of
thousands of Twitter Twitter followers
in November 2011 she was beaten arrested
and beaten in the Egyptian interior
ministry in Cairo somehow she managed to
tweet before her cellphone was taken
five chilling words beaten arrested in
interior ministry this is 2011 this is
Tahrir Square this is the this is still
you know the full Egyptian revolution
and lots of people were following her
beaten arrested in the interior ministry
so she tweeted those words at 5:44 p.m.
US Central Time and I should say it's
exactly four years ago because I was
sitting in Chicago on the Wednesday
before Thanksgiving that's and that's
why I know it was at 5:44 Central time I
was sitting there I was at my husband's
family I was a little bored so I was on
Twitter and you know family gathering so
we love them but that's so she tweets
that out at 5:44 at 6:05 I get a direct
message on Twitter for those of you
don't use Twitter it is possible to use
it more like email where somebody can
you can always send a message to someone
by by tweeting at their handle but then
everybody can see it this was a private
message from Andy Carvin Andy Carvin was
the NPR digital strategist and the top
english-language curator of tweets from
Arab protesters on the ground in
multiple countries so he was the person
meant most of us followed because we
knew that he was applying journalistic
standards to the tweets he got and you
could retweet him knowing that they had
been screened and he was he this message
told me about her tweet so he told me
that you know Mona Eltahawy has just
tweeted this out I responded to him
then immediately send an email to my
former colleagues of the State
Department known to you as Professor
Sullivan and his colleagues so I sent
because I'm out of state by now so I'm
sitting in Chicago so I sent that email
within another five minutes I'd heard
back and was able to send out a general
tweet that said the US Embassy in Cairo
was on top of the case so I'm
communicating I don't know I had
something like 70 or 80 thousand well no
not that many fifty thousand Twitter
followers lots of people watching this
Nick Kristof also used his contacts he
has millions of Twitter followers and he
sent out a similar message to all of his
followers that she that actually he had
been in touch also with the State
Department as had I and people knew
about it and the US Embassy was going to
get her out of there by then free Mona
hashtag free Mona was trending on
Twitter and a few hours later she was
free she was free with two broken bones
and a traumatic story of sexual assault
to tell majid butter butter an egyptian
blogger who was arrested with her was
also released in a world of hierarchies
we would have all been still trying to
figure out who to call I would have had
no way to get the information even if I
had the information I wouldn't know how
to communicate with someone it was only
the mass social media networks which are
spontaneously formed and our small world
networks where you have some people with
millions of followers and others with
very few but everybody thought so
everyone who followed me could see it
everybody who followed Nick Kristof and
we in turn were connected to smaller
networks but very important ones so
that's the most dramatic example I know
of where somebody's ability to tweet
five words saved her potentially from
death although not from a very
unpleasant experience from a horrible
experience
so network power also flows from the
ways in which networks build
relationships rather than routines so
I've just been talking about the
organizational power of network
now I want to talk about the relational
power of networks in crises and rapidly
evolving situations routines are
actually a handicap you're following the
routine you can't do what you need to do
the trust that comes from established
relationships allows rapid shifts in
course while keeping everyone involved
on board so Powell identified this
feature of networks as well because
quote they are typify by reciprocal
patterns of communication and exchange
which is a fancy way of saying they
depend on relationships more than
structures rules and processes they
build the trust and tacit knowledge that
support sustained but open-ended
cooperation and for those of you who
were here yesterday remember when we
talked about cooperation networks and I
said you need to have a small core of
people who interact enough that they can
actually build trust now so Powell says
okay so there's the organization
organizational dimension of being fast
being flexible being democratic meaning
anybody can participate or a much
greater number of people that can
participate then there's the relational
dimension of building building trust
social network theorist Karen Stevenson
takes that argument one step further so
see this heart markets so this is powell
that there's a world here of markets
versus hierarchies in terms of the the
the way in which people interact and
networks are in between they're
connected but they're fast and flexible
Karen Stevenson goes further and and
yeah okay Karen Stevenson goes further
and actually says powell has it wrong
that the right way to think about this
is markets hierarchies and networks are
not in between they're actually more
evolved and let me to explain what she
what she how she sees this so and again
this is pawel representation that
networks are the halfway point between
markets and hierarchies it's kind of
iconic at this point it's sort of the
invisible hand of markets in the visible
hand of hierarchy
she says actually the relevant variable
on this spectrum is the type or the
logic of exchange the type of exchange
that people are having and she says if
you think about it that way the spectrum
runs from the disinterested
non-repetitive exchanges of markets
right so you buy or sell from anybody
and it's all it can be repetitive but it
often is not to the to the repetitive
exchanges of mutual interests that
characterize networks so you start with
sort of disinterested non-repetitive all
the way to repetitive and exchanges of
mutual interests so from that point of
view it's hierarchies that are in the
middle they would they have repetitive
exchanges routine exchanges like a
network but they depend on a governing
authority right so they they they are
the way a market does so then her view
when you look at the logic of exchange
you actually get networks are on the far
end and what she's talking about is that
the mutual repetitive interested
exchanges the the repetitive exchanges
of mutual interests that kind of
exchange is the key to the power of
networks exerting a governing logic over
them I'm quoting her the alchemy of
mutual give-and-take
that over time turns to a golden trust
so she's focusing on that kind of
relationship that that leads to deep
trust and she's not talking about the
trust that you get in classic
tit-for-tat this is much deeper she's
this is the kind of trust that leads
strangers to rely on one another to
accomplish a mutual task an exponential
and this is her term shared collective
intelligence so think back to what I
talked about McChrystal talking about
yesterday general McChrystal talking
about joint cognition that this kind of
repetitive exchange within a network a
repetitive exchange of mutual interests
actually leads to being able to act as
one organism
that's the trust that flips the default
view of human nature from untrustworthy
to trustworthy and the networks that can
accomplish that transformation are
powerful generators of positive energy
and capability and for those of you who
know some of the technology literature
and the sharing economy literature and
the mesh economy literature it is all
about the culture of generosity and one
of the things that is most striking
about that vision of an economy is that
the default position of people in it
is one of trust and assumption of
goodwill rather than of distrust and
assumption of caution because you've
been in this they've been in this
network and you're constantly seeing
people actually exchange and share and
give not and again I'll come back this
doesn't mean all networks create only
positive feelings but it's a very
different view of human nature so the
but the relational dimension of human of
networked power
I think includes more than trust
although that's very important so I'm
gonna go back to what we talked about
yesterday and say the actual relational
power of networks is what I would call
you're gonna be really surprised here
given that this is called strategies of
connections strategy of connection it's
the power of connection and I would say
as I said yesterday that has multiple
facets it includes the power of
recognition and that's what we talked
about yesterday that being connected to
someone it has the the ability to to
simply have that other person see you as
an equal so when we talked about the
power of clubs and we talked about what
it is that people get as a first step
it's just being seen as a human being of
the basic human desire to be
acknowledged by fellow human beings as a
person of equal dignity and value and as
I said yesterday if you read Francis
Fukuyama and you read evolutionary
biologists they will say that is one of
the drivers of human civilization is our
desire for recognition and certainly as
a parent well frankly or is a spouse how
much of the time as a parent is
basically you just want credit you just
want people to see you and acknowledge
you right
so that's the the the power of
recognition belonging do I have to
explain the power of belonging belonging
is the power of over the overwhelming
comfort that we derive from being
members of a group and of course that's
all about us and the other and as an
entire so sociological literature there
in psychological literature now I do
want to emphasize here for those people
who have said I think rightly and also
at dinner our first night that I tend to
have an overly rosy view of networks I
tend to be an optimist so I do tend to
see things more positively but this is
this power of belonging is definitely
not not necessarily positive not at all
if you study the studies of extremist
groups from the Crips and the Bloods to
al-qaeda routinely identified the power
of being part of the family for young
men who grew up in badly broken
biological families so the idea the
power of belonging can can lead to
deeply negative outcomes as well and
then finally the power of trust as we
just talked about the power of trust is
the security of relying on others based
on long experience the willingness to
stick with them even in the face of
error and disappointment and the
certainty that they will do the same for
you and if you just think about your
relationships trust means okay you're
going to make a mistake but you're going
to tell me about it and I will stick
with you it is that that certainly in a
parental relationship it's that it is
the glue of long-term relationships
all right so that so we've talked about
the power of networks and the power they
have because they are a specific
organizational form that is extremely
well adapted for a world of rapidly
changing networks of conglomerations of
people and then we've talked about the
power of the relational power the power
of connection now I want to talk about
now I want to talk about power in
networks or more precisely the power of
how to exercise power I'm sorry
precisely the question of how to
exercise power within networks
so power in hierarchies is power over
remember the ladder here at the top
power over others power in networks is
power with the power with other so I'm
going to come back to that Joseph Nye Oh
I've talked about before he is perhaps
our preeminent theorist of power I think
he's had power in the title of his last
five books he distinguishes between
resource power rillette resources that
can produce outcomes such as money or
territory or population and his concept
of relational power which he defines as
the capacity to change the capacity to
do things and in social situations to
affect others to get the outcomes we
want so essentially when he thinks about
relational power is my power over you to
get you to do something you don't
necessarily want to do that's that's his
definition of relational power and I
contrast it to this and we're gonna come
back to this that so and in many ways
this is a passive form of relational
power this is what happens when people
come together in networks this is the
power of networks he's now turning it to
the power of how do I actually direct a
network how do I direct anything to get
results I want so no I actually borrows
from a bunch of different power
theorists and he identifies three
distinct phases of relational power so
let me yeah let me come here yes okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna do this and then I'm
gonna come back I'll back up to those so
this is how he says the relational power
and remember relational power can be
coercion and attraction hard power the
hard power of coercion and soft power
the power of attraction so he starts
with command commanding change getting
people or groups to do things they don't
want to do which I always think of as I
say to my sons you will go to camp and
my son say no I won't but that's at
least the idea is that you're commanding
change second is controlling agendas
which is the bureaucrats favorite ploy
of framing agendas for action that make
other
as other others preferences seem
irrelevant or out-of-bounds right you
know you can destroy the world you can
hope everybody's going to be in harmony
or you can take my my proposition in the
middle so you you exercise power by
framing the agenda in my camp example
would you like to go to art camp or
computer camp right so we don't we do we
don't ask about whether you're going to
camp it's just a question of which one
you go to still not all that effective
but we try the so the Third Way of power
so this is Graham Chi right for is
shaping preferences the the using ideas
beliefs and culture to shape basic
beliefs first perceptions and
preferences so it's Graham cheats
Foucault it's kittens they're many
others obviously who look at the deep
social and political structures of power
or as nine talks about think about soft
power the attraction of Hollywood movies
of American rock music of the
Declaration of Independence
those have shaped preferences in a way
people are not even aware so in my camp
example this would be we are the kind of
family where who goes to camp right this
is who we are you invoke family identity
still didn't work but that's just a
limit on parental power that is not that
I did not try all the various kinds of
power so you know Joseph and I was a
mentor of mine I have deep respect for
him that analytical framework is elegant
it's compelling and it's seemingly
comprehensive but where does the power
that toppled Mubarak come in where does
the power that freed Mona Eltahawy come
in you can't find it here it is not
about that kind of power over Nye is
interested in the power that gets people
to do things they would not have done on
their own that again that's power over a
dominant actor who exercises power over
others to compel a result the power of
opposition groups who can take to the
streets in flash mobs that are triggered
and guided by social media or in fact
the power of Twitter itself is the power
of multiple actors to get something done
with each other right it is it is
suddenly realizing I can't do this alone
but we together can do it and though and
and whether it's Twitter or other social
media or the way we have seen
revolutions break out it is it is a
process of emergence where suddenly
people realize they've got collective
power I actually originally heard the
power over versus how power with from
Lani Guinier at the Harvard Law School
back in the 1990s but it many people
have written about it and in different
ways so I've called that power
collaborative power defining it as the
power of many to do together
what no one can do alone consider the
power of water each drop is harmless but
enough drops together create a tsunami
that can level a landscape now more
recently since I wrote about
collaborative power jeremy hymens and
henry tim's writing in the Harvard
Business Review draw a more sweeping
distinction between old closed
hierarchical power and new power and
they say old power works like a currency
it is held by few once gained it is
jealously guarded and the powerful have
a substantial store of it to spend it is
closed inaccessible and leader driven it
downloads and it captures they also like
the liquid metaphor I said think think
about it as like think about this like
water this is how they describe new
power new power operates differently
like a current it is made by many it is
open participatory and peer driven it
uploads and it distributes like water or
electricity it is most forceful when it
surges the goal with new power is not to
hoard it but to channel it and one way
to think about this is to think about
Occupy Wall Street all those buildings
all those banks that's old power the
power of Occupy Wall Street and again it
has limits I'm not we're going to talk
about its limits but
that power of and what did change the
national conversation that power in
front of a debt on Wall Street that was
new power so this is how this is how
hymens and Tim's describe the new power
and that again this is a that they've
got a book coming out where they're
actually now thinking about the new
power in a business context this was
published in the Harvard Business Review
this is not not technologists or
revolutionaries so this is how they
describe the new power and it's all
about the architecture of participation
its how the power comes from
participating as they said from sharing
not from hoarding from the many not the
few so consuming this is all power
sharing shaping remix another people's
content or ideas funding so when you
think about Kickstarter and increasingly
we're gonna peer-to-peer lending or Kiva
any all the different ways we are now
funding and we're just beginning the
disruption of the financial industry or
the disintermediation of the financial
industry producing I mean a you you all
know examples like this now right you
can design your own Nike shoes
increasingly people all the corporations
understand that they will do far better
if they let you participate in what it
is that they're actually selling and
ultimately co-owning all right and that
goes back to Wikipedia which we talked
about yesterday so if you think that's
old power versus new power Knives vision
of power versus what I called
collaborative power here's the problem
you can describe that power quite well
right I can describe
described it in terms of a kind of
emergence when I said think about the
revolutionary power of people coming on
to the streets you can describe it it is
indeed when you describe it a pure
distributed network right I mean it
suddenly you know people people you you
or well actually I should say it's
anyone any one of these networks you can
see it and you can map it we talked
about it yesterday in terms of the
spider and the starfish we said you know
participants move in a kind of synchrony
with
out central direction that's the the
mesh network on the on the far right
your far right but in all the networks
that we've looked at
we haven't assumed this right and the
networks we've looked at we've assumed
that somebody the policymaker would
actually be creating a network for a
specific purpose and then assume the
existence of one or more central nodes
charged with leading or at least guiding
or directing and we're gonna talk about
what leadership means in that context
that network but in this how do you
actually do that how does that
individual group exercise power with
because power with can be described as
at their collective power but how do you
summon it how do you evoke it how do you
use it
okay so then let me come back to the way
I think about what you can actually do
with the power of collaboration or than
or or call it the new power all right
and you'll have noticed by now I'm a
person who thinks in threes so instead
of command you have the power of
mobilizing you cannot make people do
things but you can send out information
that says we are all gathering here and
we are all going to do this
that's mobilizing people it's this
traditional community organizing and it
if I mean command doesn't always work
mobilization doesn't always work but
it's a similar tool it and generally you
immobilize through some kind of
call-to-action the second face is
connection itself the site instead of
controlling an agenda what the you can
are controlling a specific set of
choices you exercise power by broadening
access to the circle of power and
connecting as many people as possible to
one another and to a common purpose so
here instead again think of the old and
new power you're not hoarding power
you're not excluding people quite the
contrary
what you're actually and you're
certainly not controlling the agenda
you're actually opening it up you're
sharing your connect
as many people as possible to power and
then as I said to a common purpose that
connecting often does take place for
sharing that's through a culture of
generosity and a third phase is
adaptation as and this is really deeply
counterintuitive but in supposed to the
deep structural shape the preferences of
others if you're going to exercise power
in a network you don't to be able to
influence others you have to prove that
they can influence you you actually have
to prove that you're willing to change
your preferences if you want them to
change theirs if you think about trying
to persuade someone if you're having an
argument with somebody and if they know
that no matter what they say you are not
going to change your mind you're not
going to get anywhere you say because
they know this isn't really about
persuasion this is about power if you
want to persuade someone you have got to
demonstrate that when they make a point
that you hadn't thought of it changes
your mind and when you do that that
shifts to ah we are actually in
something that now looks more like a
brainstorm or a collective joint effort
to figure something out and they will
change their mind so then in
collaborative power rather than trying
to shape their preferences or you the
way you shape their preferences you
adapt your own preferences you do not
have a fixed set of preferences that you
then instantiate or structure so that
they borrow them so very different ways
of actually exercising these two types
of power
command control and shaping mobilizing
connecting and adapting okay so now
we're going to turn so when we talk
about these mechanisms through which
powers exercised basically we're talking
about leadership in the passive voice
I'm saying power is exercised let's turn
to the active voice of leadership so
think about thinking about how children
are introduced to leadership follow the
leader
I think it's amazing that's how most
children first ever hear of leadership
follow the leader it is the game we play
as children and it's the assumption
we make as adults that effective action
in any organization require requires
some delete and others to follow so
indeed when we're back in when we were
looking at the Egyptian revolution the
New York Times had a story about the
forces in Tahrir Square and said a quest
for an opposition leader the story
listed Wael Ghonim who was a facebook
activist Nobel Prize winner Mohamed
ElBaradei
Muslim Brotherhood leader Mohamed body
God party leader Ayman Nour and another
Nobel Prize winner the chemist Ahmed
zewail a and note they're all men those
all of those were people who were that
they could be the opposition leader
because the New York Times could not
believe that you could have a revolution
without a Trotsky and Lenin somewhere
right that was the idea you know there's
got to be some guys somewhere here
directing this um but if you reread the
story if you looked at the story it was
became very clear that the quest for a
leader came from the New York Times and
not actually from the opposition
protesters and Wael Ghonim who did
mobilize lots of people through his
Facebook page rejected the leadership
mantle now the reason in part is that
they are the web generation that their
concept of leadership was very different
they didn't see the world in terms of
atomized actors requiring leaders to
represent them and to organize
cooperation but rather they saw
themselves as a vast network of
interconnected individuals and in that
world organizing is easy and almost
organic I don't want to overstate this
because yesterday I did talk about the
ways in which a core in Serbia managed
to mobilize people to overthrow
Milosevic and I talked about how that
model had replicated through Tunisia and
to Egypt so it's not weird on this it's
not as if this was all completely
spontaneous people did understand the
tools of how to make organize how to
make this attractive to others but in
the moment this was not this was as far
from the Russian Revolution as you could
imagine so the the
so essentially what they were doing was
creating a webpage that tweeting what
they were doing was to disseminate
information to convince people they were
not alone there were many like-minded
people and if they all acted together
they had power so the leaders in that
world because it wasn't actually
completely leaderless but it was
leadership of a very different kind do
not chart a course for others to follow
or even represent the views of their own
followers as I said it has to be deeply
interactive they they were central nodes
in multiple networks individuals who
convened connected catalyzed and
facilitated other's action and who made
it possible for as many different people
as possible to come together and solve
their problems or come together in
protest so that's what ganene did Wael
Ghonim did he created the Facebook page
we are all Khalid Saeed giving tens of
thousands of people a place to come
together make their views known and draw
strength from there gathering numbers
and indeed in an interview ganene said
our purpose my purpose is to increase
the bond between the people and the
group through my unknown personality
this way we create an army of volunteers
now I will say they also had many
disincentives to identify a leader right
that's exactly what the government
wanted was to put an individual face on
the movement and what the New York Times
couldn't imagine could happen without an
individual face
so obviously individuals then could be
arrested and silenced and even you know
even when you have the the the the other
point obviously was was worrying that if
you identified leaders you quickly would
develop a hierarchy that no matter what
you tried the minute you sort of said
here's the leader here's the leader
here's leader they would meet and then
suddenly you would lose that spontaneity
and they also rejected the idea they
were representing anybody I think did
not want to say we are the people I mean
Wael Ghonim
was a you know of a Google employee
write-ins he didn't represent the
majority of the people who are in the
streets so that's the kind of leadership
for bringing people
into the streets as we saw that kind of
leadership that kind of action was very
effective for overthrowing the Egyptian
government it did not work to govern in
its stead as we have now seen repeatedly
so then so the you can use that kind of
power to mobilize as I said to connect
to create markets to sell things to
overthrow things you can't use that kind
of leadership to then actually govern
and I come back to policy right the idea
that we need to solve public problems we
that is the business of government it's
the business of policy schools and think
tanks and policy makers wherever they
are so that then leads us finally to a
way of thinking about leadership that
would allow you to benefit from this
kind of power but also have a more
traditional notion of leadership and
here I'm going to draw on my favorite
definition of leadership from that
nanner old Cohan who was president of
Wellesley and then president of Duke and
wrote a wonderful book about thinking
about leadership and her definition of
leaders as leaders determine or clarify
goals for determine or clarify note the
sharing idea right that you clarify what
people want rather than deciding
determine or clarify goals for a group
of individuals and bring together the
energies of members of that group to
accomplish those goals it is a deeply
collaborative vision of what leadership
is not completely right and believe me
nan Cohan knows how to exercise power
when she coercive power when she has to
but that is not how she starts her
definition of leadership we're running
out of time weren't we have much time
okay all right okay so so as I said and
and she is you know served on the board
of corporations she ran a major
university think about what this vision
of leadership looks like in different
types of networks and let's think about
the networks we talked about yesterday
so we started with resilience Network
and I talked about a stabilization and
assistance network for Ukrainian
government officials that would embed
them in in pods of EU and international
officials so okay so this is that
central remember I said you want to
think about a stabilization and
assistance network where you have a
center but you have different groups of
officials and they're in these pods and
those pods are all connected and that
uses the power of peer pressure of
positive peer pressure and it provides
moral support it raises standards that
kind of network would not work on its
own and I said that yesterday we'd come
back to what it has to look like today
you need at the center the ador or at
the center of at the center of each one
of these networks of different types of
officials some respected figure like a
former finance minister if you have
finance ministers central banker justice
minister as the leader of the network
that peer pressure only works among
groups that are actively engaged with
one another to care about each other's
opinions well you can't just connect
people you have to actually foster that
interaction without that you don't get
any of the the benefits of actually
being part of the group and trust
similarly is essential for officials who
are from the governments who need to be
stabilized they have to trust the other
members of the group to be able to ask
for support so the leadership position
of a senior official is not titular it
actually would require a willingness to
stimulate an ongoing level of activity
in the group it means that leader has to
continually ping the network to stick
trigger the exchange of information to
constantly be asking what's going on
what do you need constantly cross
fertilizing connecting it means the
creation of subgroups by connecting
pairs or trios of members to address
specific issues to make valuable
introductions in the private and the
civic sectors and to foster regular sus
side meetings and sub meetings the
leader the person in the center has to
consider sparking and weaving
relationships and orchestrating activity
among group members as a genuine job
which we never when we create networks
we do not think about paying people to
be connectors and orchestrators and and
ascent cross fertilizers that work of
weaving relationships is essential if
such a network is to work so if you just
connect Ukrainian ministers in any area
with their peers in the EU and I
suggested in in the US or in Canada
without somebody exercising that kind of
leadership at the center of the network
it will not work and it must be somebody
who's respected so that other people
answer their emails and it must be
somebody who considers it a job to weave
those relationships to build that trust
so the the again if you can think about
that with any different kinds of
networks you know you the you could you
could have one person you could have a
group of people but again if you had a
group of people at the centre they would
all have to think of their their job
that way so that's a that's a result
that was a kind of resilience Network
building stabilization and assistance
networks now think about leadership in a
scale network and yesterday we talked
about different kinds of scale networks
replication networks coordination
networks humilation networks I gave the
example of the Global Alliance for
vaccines and immunization Gavi and I
said that had pulled together the Gates
Foundation the World Health Organization
UNICEF and the World Bank to work with
developed and developed country
governments and pharmaceutical
organizations and research and technical
institutes Gavi also will not work
without a very strong central node and
Gabi was more this kind of a network
it's more of a starry network and but
again as within that node you have to
have connectors communicators across
fertilizers and collaboration managers
lots of C's working actively to activate
the links among the different nodes and
to click create new ones and if you
don't do that you create this network
but it exists mostly on paper
philanthropy philanthropist jeffrey
walker who studied how to create cause
based collaborations that's what he
would call Gavi i call it her a
coordination network he would call it a
cause based collaboration he and he
identifies the central importance of
quote an honest and unbiased broker a
superb networker a troubleshooter and
problem solver who quote can bring
people together and find the common
linkages among members of a disparate
group that person he calls the
collaboration managers other people call
a partnership broker and there's
actually a degree for partnership
brokers at Cambridge and that person is
a super node it's a way to think about
it or they or a group of the super node
contains people like that he would also
say that you the the group of people at
the center of Gavi create the
collaborative glue for the entire
network and that's so again you can have
one person or in a in a big scale
network you actually need a group of
people but this is how they have to
understand what they do we also talked
about action networks I talked about
innovation networks these are the
services from the business literature
and the way business leaders write about
managing the ecosystem the open
innovation ecosystem and the questions
are how to build trust what are the most
important management tasks of network
orchestrators I'm going to slide here
and is it necessary to manage the entire
value network or merely a small clique
of central players and remember we
looked at one of the action networks
yesterday the cooperation network and I
said you have to have that small cleek
and then you go out beyond that alright
the last thing I'm going to say then
about how you lead in action networks
comes again from stanley mcchrystal x'
team of teams and this is how he
described ultimately what I said was
both a small world network and a
complete Network superimposed on top of
each other and I'm reading his book and
imagine my surprise he's a general we
think of general you know look at that
follow the leader
think the general on the white horse and
the troops follow it's the absolutely
ingrained notion of old leadership and
I'm reading this book and I come to the
chapter subhead that says from
Chessmaster to Gardner the leaders we
need what now now I'm I love this
because he says Chessmaster and I'm
thinking that's great this is perfectly
useful for me I read this book last year
just sort of because I thought it was
important and then he said some
Chessmaster to Gardner and he lays out
the characteristics of what of what he
calls leavening as gardening and the
principle idea is that instead of
directing a leader gardener this is a
four-star general talking a leader
gardener quote creates an environment in
which the plants can flourish the word
the the work is done upfront the work
done upfront and vigilant maintenance eg
weeding if you've ever gardened allows
the plants to grow individually and all
at the same time so I was really struck
by this but for reasons you'll be
surprised here so first because george
shultz who is also a mentor of mine oh
it describes in him memoirs the work of
diplomacy as gardening he says really
what diplomacy is about is tending
relationships and pulling weeds so that
when you need those relationships
they're there for you in a crisis which
is again striking from from man who was
Secretary of State and Secretary of the
Treasury but I was even more struck
because I had was writing a chapter
about leadership as gardening let me
close these lectures by bringing the two
halves of my life together I was writing
a book I was writing a chapter I've got
it still called leading as gardening in
a book about women men work and family
in a book about leadership based on care
that chapter did not make it into
unfinished business but it will make it
into this book and I just want to close
then by saying so how did how did I get
to leading as gardening at the same in
the same way that Stanley McChrystal got
to leading as gardening and the reason
is that I was giving a talk two years
ago or a year ago it would to a group of
women CEOs and one of them stood up and
said that effectively she talked about a
CEO being a caregiver of tending the
organization that she leads and indeed
then I was listening to a NPR interview
with named Stephanie Shirley who is a
very successful British serial
entrepreneur and on this interview she
compared growing a company to growing a
garden talking about the ways in which
she quote nurtured and cared for the
enterprise
she said she allowed her employees to
have flexible home-based schedules and
she reaped the benefits of the
arrangement when she needed to take time
off herself and she said what happened
was people worked very well without me
because I had built a an organization
and when I was developing management I
think of myself quote as a sort of
gardener I grow organic for independent
charities my friend Barbara Byrne who is
the vice chair of Barclays Bank and a
member of the very tiny number of women
in finance said exactly the same thing
when we were standing at her house at a
birthday party with a lot of women
around her and we were admiring her
garden and she said we're talking about
women at work my greatest satisfaction
at work comes from investing and growing
talent just like I grow my garden I
nurture both into bloom now if I just
told you all that talking about
unfinished business you just said yes
that's a woman's way of leading it's not
a woman's way of leading I just quoted
General Stanley McChrystal talking about
leadership from chess master to gardener
it is an entrepreneur's way of leaving
an inventor's a stewards and a network
managers anyone who must nurture and
grow an idea a team or an organization
it is a style of leadership particularly
well-suited to alliances and networks
loose arrangements held together as much
by trust and commitment to a mutual
mission and to each as to each other by
on bonuses and if you doubt me just
check out the current crop of corporate
management books all of which are about
leading by nurturing and empowering
teams so let me close on leadership and
then I will close the lectures as a
whole leading as caring leading as
gardening leading as tending leading as
empowering these are all ways of
describing leadership in a world of
connections in a world of networks in
the world of networks that I have
described the world of the web the
chessboard world requires leadership as
command or as shaping preferences and
setting agendas the web world requires
leadership as care as gardening as
mobilizing as sharing as adapting let me
conclude by once again saying how
grateful I am to be asked to have given
these lectures I they are essentially a
unified field theory of everything I
have been working on since I started
certainly since 1994 which is when I
first conceived the book to first
conceived the idea of writing a book
about networks but I meant government
networks I wrote that book I started
started in 1994 in 2004 I had two
children along the way it took a long
time to get that first book done that
was the book a new world order and it
talked also about changing mental maps
about disagree as disaggregating the
state and learning to see the
international system not in terms of
traditional international organizations
like the UN and the World Bank and the
IMF but in terms of networks of
government officials so I talked about
the Basel Committee and the networks of
finance ministers and justice ministers
and I said this is the new world order
networks of government ministers so that
was 2004 I in 2009 as I said I wrote
about power in a network
world and what how to think about the
United States if we thought of the web
world I didn't call it the web world
done but if we thought of the web world
we would see the United States place in
that world very differently and the
potential of the United States very
differently that's all lecture one
that's showing you how to think about
the world as the chessboard and the web
that led me to understand and the
experiencing government so deeply
reinforced the that we we can see the
world that way but we don't know how to
operate in the world that way we have no
idea how to actually create policy and
strategy that way at the same time I was
becoming increasingly immersed in the
world of technology I was hanging out
with Civic entrepreneurs and then became
head of New America and now spent half
my time with technologist and so I was
seeing what was possible I was seeing
networks or networked organizations
enabled by technology they were doing
extraordinary things and I asked why
can't we take that and put it into
government now Mike asked me yesterday
for Mike's never gonna have dinner with
me ever again because he realizes but
last night he said in the military we
think about networks all the time
but we think about networks as tactics
we don't think about networks at the
strategic level and yet this lecture is
these lectures are called the strategy
of connection strategy requires big
thinking and indeed here at Yale you
have the grand strategy program you have
the understood that really you know what
George Kennan was master of and will
always be remembered for the grand
strategy of containment
it requires understanding the world in a
certain way it requires understanding
power in a certain way and capabilities
in a certain way today if we're going to
have that grand strategy if we're going
to actually be able to elaborate a grand
strategy of connection and in a grand
strategy to work in a world of
connection and not just a world of
conflict and competition then we have to
be able to see the networks that are out
there we have to understand how to shape
them there
structured their content and we have to
understand how to exercise power and
leadership within them that would then
allow us to address the problems that we
face not only the problems of the 19th
and the 20th century worlds but the
terrible problems we face in the 21st
century world using both the chess board
and the web thank you very much
you